Hay algo más que pueden hacer para protegerte
de los síntomas del alzhéimer,
aunque su cerebro parezca tener un cuadro patológico completo.
Tiene que ver con la neuroplasticidad y la reserva cognitiva.
Recuerden, la experiencia de tener alzhéimer
es en última instancia el resultado de perder sinapsis.
En promedio, un cerebro tiene más de 100 billones de sinapsis,
lo que es fantástico; tenemos mucho con qué trabajar.
Y no es un número estático.
Ganamos y perdemos sinapsis todo el tiempo,
mediante un proceso llamado neuroplasticidad.
Cada vez que aprendemos algo nuevo,
creamos y fortalecemos conexiones neuronales nuevas,
sinapsis nuevas.
En el 'Estudio de las monjas',
678 monjas, todas sobre los 75 años, al inicio del estudio,
fueron observadas por más de dos décadas.
Se expusieron regularmente a exámenes físicos y cognitivos,
y, al morir, donaron sus cerebros para una autopsia.
Los científicos descubrieron algo sorprendente en algunos cerebros.
A pesar de la presencia de placas, ovillos y atrofia cerebral,
lo que aparentaba ser alzhéimer sin lugar a dudas,
las monjas a las que pertenecían los cerebros no demostraron síntomas
de esta enfermedad mientras vivían.
¿Cómo puede ser?
Pensamos que se debe a que las monjas tenían un alto grado de reserva cognitiva,
lo que significa que tenían más sinapsis funcionales.
Las personas con más años de educación formal,
con un alto grado de alfabetismo,
que suelen involucrarse en actividades que estimulan la mente,
todas tienen una reserva cognitiva mayor.
Tienen una abundancia y una redundancia de conexiones neurales.
Así que, aunque tengan una enfermedad como el alzhéimer
que comprometa algunas de las sinapsis,
tienen muchas conexiones de respaldo adicionales,
y esto las protege de darse cuenta de que algo anda mal.
Pongamos un ejemplo simplificado.
Digamos que solo saben una cosa de un tema.
Digamos que es sobre mí.
Saben que Lisa Genova escribió "Siempre Alice",
y es lo único que saben sobre mí.
Tienen esa única conexión neural,
una sola sinapsis.
Ahora imaginemos que tienen alzhéimer.
Tienen placas, ovillos, inflamación
y microglía devorando la sinapsis.
Ahora cuando alguien les pregunta, "Oye, ¿quién escribió 'Siempre Alice'?",
no se acuerdan,
porque esa sinapsis está fallando o desapareció.
Me han olvidado para siempre.
Pero ¿qué sucede si aprenden más de mí?
Digamos que saben cuatro cosas sobre mí.
Ahora imaginemos que tienen alzhéimer,
y tres de esas sinapsis están dañadas o destruidas.
Aún tienen una manera de darle la vuelta.
Aún puedes recordar mi nombre.
Podemos resistir la presencia de una patología de alzhéimer
mediante el desarrollo de rutas en buen estado.
Y creamos estas rutas, esta reserva cognitiva,
al aprender cosas nuevas.
Idealmente, se quiere que estas novedades sean lo más ricas en significado posible,
involucrado la vista, la audición, las asociaciones y las emociones.
En realidad, esto no se refiere a hacer crucigramas.
No quieren simplemente recuperar información ya aprendida,
porque esto es como viajar por calles ya familiares,
cruzar vecindarios que ya conocen.
Quieren crear nuevas carreteras neuronales.
Fortalecer el cerebro contra el alzhéimer
significa aprender a hablar italiano,
hacer nuevas amistades,
leer un libro,
o escuchar una gran charla de TED.
Y si, a pesar de todo esto, algún día les diagnostican con alzhéimer,
hay tres lecciones que aprendí de mi abuela
y de docenas de personas que he conocido que viven con la enfermedad.
El diagnóstico no quiere decir que morirán mañana.
Continúa su vida.
No perderán su memoria sentimental.
Aún podrán sentir amor y felicidad.
Tal vez no recuerden lo que dije hace cinco minutos,
pero recordarán cómo les hice sentir.
Y somos más de lo que recordamos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)